though judges that gave four rounds of
one I think that's a little extreme
three to two is fair depending how you
score it all depends how you score the
second fourth round the second or fourth
is where this fight was determined you
know the fifth Claire's day the first
clearest day the third you would should
probably give it to volkanovsky right
you give voklowski the third and the
fifth that's easy you'd have to find him
around in one two and four the fourth
round gets a little dicey because
although volkonowski is being controlled
which is dominant position when he had
that body lock volkanovski was Landing
shots there but he was still being
controlled and they weren't significant
shots we put up a great fight and we
realized how good voknowsky is on the
ground my god dude good luck at 45
beating them